so we are asked to drag the point to
12.5 on the number line so let's see you
can see this is twelve and then twelve
point five is halfway between twelve and
thirteen then they say what is twelve
point five rounded to the nearest tenth
well what's cool about this is you can
see on the number line that our tens are
in this blue hash so we have ten and
then 20 and we're between ten and twenty
and which one are we closer to which is
literally the nearest ten well you can
see we're closer to 10 than we are to 20
so you would say ten and this helps us
build an intuition for what rounding to
the nearest 10 even means because you
might know a rule like hey look you go
one place less than the tens place which
would be the ones place and if it's less
than five there you round down to ten if
it's five or greater you round up to 20
but you see why over here we are just
closer to ten let's do another example
here so here it says drag the point to
zero point one three six so this is zero
point one three this is zero point one
four so this is 1300s and this is 1400s
now let's see there's one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten so these
are you could think of it as the ten
thousandth between these two hundredths
so we want to go thirteen hundreds and
then another six thousandths so let's
see we go one two three four five six
just like that and then they say what is
this number 136 thousandths or 0.136
rounded to the nearest hundredth well we
have our hundreds in blue here and which
one are we closer to well we're closer
to 1400s 0.14 and that's consistent with
what we've seen in other cases where you
look at the thousandths place and if
it's five or greater you round up in
this case you would round up to 14
hundredths let's do a few more examples
here so let's say that so they're asking
us which point is at forty four point
one nine seven on the number line so
let's see that's going to be between 44
and 45 so
- right over here 44.1 97 so that would
be point C and then they say what is
forty four point one nine seven round
rounded to the nearest whole number
well there's a couple of ways to think
about it you could just look at the
tenths place and say look that's less
than 5 so we round down to 44 or a more
intuitive way of thinking about is like
look Point C is the number we care about
that is 44 point one nine seven is it
close what's the closest whole number to
it is the closer to 44 or is it closer
to 45 well it's clearly closer to 44 and
so that's another reason why 44 makes a
lot of sense let's do let's do another
example let's say that we want to so
they say what is a rounded to the
nearest thousandth what is a rounded to
the nearest hundredth so a is right over
here like let's get our bearings so zero
point seven that seven hundredths this
is eight hundredths right over here and
then between them let's see this looks
like it's zero this is so you could view
this as seventy thousand seventy one
thousand seventy two thousand seventy
three thousand seventy four thousands
and so on so this is between 78
thousands and seventy nine thousandths
so if we round to the nearest thousandth
it looks closer in fact it's definitely
closer to seventy eight thousandths than
it is to 79 thousandths so I would say
this is zero point zero seven eight or
78 thousands it's closer that's the
nearest thousandth what is a rounded to
the nearest hundredth well what are the
hundreds that it's in between it's in
between seven hundredths and eight
hundredths and which one is it closer to
well it's closer to eight hundredths
0.08 so once again the whole point of
this video is to appreciate when people
say round to the nearest whole number to
the nearest ten to the nearest
thousandth to the nearest hundredth you
can think of it on a number line and
just say well what is the closest
hundredth to it or what hundredth is it
closest to which thousandth is it
closest to on the number line